the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we're really moving along this review
of highlights of linear algebra and
today it's matrices Q they get that name
there they have orthonormal columns so
that's what one looks like and then the
key fact orthonormal columns translates
directly into that simple fact that you
just keep remembering every time you see
Q transpose Q you've got the identity
matrix let's just see why so Q transpose
would be I'll take those columns and
make them into rows and then I multiply
by Q with the columns and what do I get
well hopefully I get the identity matrix
okay
why because oh yeah the normal part
tells me that the lengths of each vector
that's the length squared Q transpose Q
the length squared is 1 so that gives me
the 1 in the identity matrix along the
diagonal and then Q transpose times a
different Q is 0 that's the ortho part
so that gives me the zeros so that's a
simple identity but it translates from a
lot of words into a simple expression
now does that mean that in the other
order Q Q transpose is that the identity
that's so that's a question to think
about is QQ transpose equal the identity
question
sometimes yes sometimes no easy to tell
which the answer is yes yes when Q is
square the answer is yes if Q is a
square matrix a square matrix a this is
saying that the square matrix Q has that
inverse on its left but for square
matrices a left inverse Q transpose is
also a right inverse so for a square
matrix if you have an inverse that works
on one side it will work on the other
side so the answer is yes in that case
and then in that case that's the case
when we call Q is well we really don't
know what the right name would be but
here's the name everybody uses an
orthogonal matrix and that's that's only
in their square case square here is an
orthogonal matrix right right do you -
do you want to just see an example of
how that works and it will not so if Q
is rectangular let's let me do a
rectangular Q and square Q okay square
all right good to see some orthogonal
matrices because my message is that
they're really important in all kinds of
applications let's start two-by-two I
can think of two different ways to get
an orthogonal matrix that's a 2 by 2
matrix and one of them you will know
immediately cos theta sine theta so
that's a unit vector it's normalized cos
squared plus sine squared is 1 and this
guy has to be orthogonal to it
so I make that - sine theta and cos
theta okay
those are both links one they're
orthogonal then this is my Q and the
inverse of Q will be the transpose if I
multiply the transpose would put the
minus sign down here and would produce
the inverse matrix and what is that
particular matrix represent whoa why do
geometrically why do we where do we see
that matrix it's a rotation thank you
it's a rotation of the whole plane by
SATA
yeah so so if I apply that to one zero
for example I get the first column which
is cos theta sine theta and that's just
a rope let me draw a picture that vector
1 0 has got rotated up - so there's the
the 1 0 and there it got rotated through
an angle theta and similarly 0 1 will
get rotated through an angle theta 2
there so the whole plane rotates oh that
makes me remember a highly important
very important property of Q it doesn't
change length the length of any vector
is the same after you rotate it the
length of any vector is the same after
you multiply by Q can I just do that
I claim any X any vector X I want to
look at the length of Q X and I claim
that it has the same length as X
actually that's the reason in
computations that orthogonal matrix are
so much loved because no overflow can
happen with orthogonal matrices lengths
don't change I can multiply by any
number of orthogonal matrices and the
lengths don't change can we just see why
that's true how would you so what do we
have to go on we
what we have to go on is Q transpose Q
equal I whenever we're gonna prove it's
got to come out of that because that's
all we know so how do I use that to get
that
well we haven't said a whole lot about
lengths but you'll see it all now it'll
be easier to prove that the squares are
the same so what's the what's the matrix
expression for the length squared what's
what's the right-hand side of that
equation X transpose X right X transpose
X gives me the sum of the squares
Pythagoras says that's the length
squared so that right hand side is X
transpose X what's the left side
it's a length squared of this of QX so
it must be the same as hue X transpose
QX and the claim is that that equation
holds and do you see it
whereís so any property if from Q is
going to has to just come out directly
from that where is it here do I just
like push away a little bit at that left
hand side and see it
QX transpose is the same as X transpose
Q transpose and QX is QX and now I'm
seeing well you might say wait a minute
the parentheses were there and there but
I say the most important law for matrix
multiplication is you can move
parentheses or throw them away let's
roam away so in here I'm seeing Q
transpose Q which is the identity so
it's it's true yeah so that means that
you're never underflow or overflow when
you're multiplying by Q every numerical
algorithm is written to use orthogonal
matrices if wherever it can can okay and
here's the first example
I think maybe good for me to think of
other examples or for us to think of
other examples of orthogonal matrices so
I'm using that word orthogonal matrix I
should it really should we should really
be saying orthonormal and I'm really
thinking mostly of square ones so so the
so in the square case when Q transpose
is Q inverse of course that fact makes
it easy to solve all equations that have
Q as a coefficient matrix because you
want the inverse and you just use the
transpose okay let's just take a some
minutes to think of examples of Q's if
they're so important there have to be
interesting examples and that was a
first one now there's one more
two-by-two example that I that you
should know do you know what that would
be
so another this will be example two and
it's also going to be only two by two
and real and what possibility have I got
left here I'll use the same first column
cos theta sine theta because that's more
or less any any unit vector in two
dimensions this has got that form so
what do you propose for the second
column
yes yeah put the put the minus sign down
here so you think does that make any
difference so sine theta and minus cos
theta I don't know if you've ever looked
at that matrix you know we're trying to
collect together a few matrices that are
worth knowing are worth looking at okay
now what kind of what's happened here
you may say that was a trivial change
which it kind of was but it's a
different matrix now it's not a rotation
anymore
that's not a rote
and yeah somehow now it's symmetric and
[Music]
yeah what its eigenvectors must be
something or other we'll get to those
but what did what does that matrix do I
don't know I don't know if you've seen
it if you haven't it's not it doesn't
jump out but it's a important case this
is a reflection matrix notice that it's
determined it is minus 1 you have minus
cos squared theta minus sine squared
theta it's determinate is minus 1
there's some some some eigenvalue it
coming up with that that's got a - yeah
ok so what do I mean by a reflection
matrix let me draw the plane and I think
so so 1 0 let's follow it follow again 1
0 where does that go
that gives me the first column so as
before it goes to cos theta sine theta
and when I say reflection let me put put
the the mirror into the picture so you
see what reflection it is the mirror is
is along here at angle fate / - stayed
over to live so sure enough 1 0 at angle
0 got reflected into a unit vector at
angle theta and halfway between was the
saito virtu line that's that's not
that's okay now what about the other guy
0 1
here's 0 1 ok I multiply that can I put
the 0 1 up here so you just your eye
does the multiplication where is the
result of 0 1 what's the output from
from cue applied to zero one sine theta
minus cos theta right it's the it's the
second column and so where is that
well it's perpendicular to that guy
that's right I know right that was the
point that the two columns are
perpendicular so it's so it must go down
this way right sine theta cos theta and
it doesn't change lengths all these
facts that we just learned are key so
there's there's zero one and it goes to
this guy which is whatever that second
column is sine theta minus cos theta and
if you check that actually like plain
geometry I believe never occurred to me
before but I believe it that that this
angle going down to there that that goes
straight through and that the halfway
one is that line yeah I think that
picture is got it and I think it's in
the note so that's a reflection matrix
well that's a two-by-two reflection
matrix would you like to see some other
matrices like this one but but larger
they're named after a guy named
householder so these are householder
reflections what am I doing here I'm
collecting together some orthogonal
matrices that are useful and important
and householder found a whole bunch of
them and and his algorithm is a much
used part of numerical linear algebra so
he started with a unit vector start with
a unit vector
you transpose u equal 1 so the length of
the vector is 1 and then he created
let's name it after him H he created
this matrix the identity minus 2 uu
transpose and I believe that that's a
really useful matrix so it's just like I
think this review is like going beyond
1806 into what is what ones are really
worth knowing that worth knowing
individually ok could we just check what
are the properties of house holders
reflection of that I - to you you
recognize here column times a row so
that's a matrix and what kind of what
could you tell me about that matrix u u
transpose it's yeah so uh or what what
can we say about about about H so I
guess I'm believing that H is a
orthogonal matrix otherwise it wouldn't
be here today
so I believe that and that not only is
it orthogonal it is also have a look at
it symmetric it's also symmetric the
identity symmetric uu transpose is
symmetric so that this is a family of
symmetric orthogonal matrices and that
was one of them that's a symmetric
orthogonal matrix these matrices are
really great to have you just like in in
using linear algebra it's you just get a
collection of useful matrices that you
can call on and these are definitely one
family well it's obviously symmetric
shall we check that it's orthogonal so
to check that it's orthogonal I just so
I'm going to check that H transpose H is
the identity can I just check that
well H transpose is the same as H
because it was symmetric so I'm gonna
square this guy this is really H times H
I'm squaring it and what do I get if I
square so so I get I hope I get the
identity but let's see it what do I get
when I Square this get little multiply
it out
so I times I is I and then I get some
number of uu transpose this how many do
I get for that from that so I'm squaring
this thing because H transpose H is the
same as H times H so I'm squaring it so
how many what do I put here for thanks
and now I've got this guy squared with a
plus so that's four uu transpose uu
transpose
yeah I'm totally realizing I've
practiced for a lifetime doing these
dinky little calculations but they are
dinky and you'll get the hang of it
quickly now what am i hoping out of that
bottom line that it is I hope you to get
I do we get I yes we're who sees how to
get eye out of that thing yeah u
transpose u in here is a number that was
you that was column times row times
column times row and I look at the in
the middle here is Rho times column and
that's the number one right because it's
there so that's one and then I have
minus four of that plus four of that
they cancel each other and I get I so
those are good matrices we'll we'll use
them we'll use them actually they're
better than gram-schmidt so we'll use
them in in making things orthogonal
so what what other orthogonal matrices
let's create some you know creating
Gordo orthogonal matrices is you know
it's it pays off let's think so there's
a family named after this French guy who
lived to a hundred he was a real old
timer
well MIT had a faculty member in math
when I came professor strike who lived
to a hundred and six and I heard him
give a lecture at Brown University at
age 100 and it was like perfect you
could not have done it better so he's my
inspiration I'm keep going I only have
like 10 more years to get there well
it's too many anyway okay Adam re all
right
so Adam art he created well that's the
simplest the smallest now the next guy
is gonna be four by four I'm going to
put that so where I see a one I'm gonna
put Adam artis 1 1 1 minus 1 1 1 1 minus
1 and then when I see a minus I'm gonna
put it in with a minus
you saw that picture it was a picture of
H 2 H 2 h 2 and minus H 2 that's what
I've got there and I believe those
columns are orthogonal right now what
could I do
well it's not quite an orthogonal matrix
what do I have to do to make this isn't
quite an orthogonal matrix either what
what do I do to make that an orthogonal
matrix /
square root of two I need I need unit
vectors there and here those lengths are
1 squared 1 squared 4 square root of 4
is 2 so I better divided by the 2 there
and now here I'm gonna here I'm up to
yeah so that was that one don't tell me
the next one up what's that going to be
8 by 8 what's that so this is H 4 here
oops 4 so tell me what I should do 4 8
by 8 you'll think this is like simple
but that's that's a good thing to say
about it you know they're in encoding
theory all sorts of places you want
matrices of ones and minus ones
ok what's H 8 I'm gonna build it out of
H 4 so what am I gonna what's it going
to be I'm gonna put an H for there what
am I going to put here another H 4 and
up here another H 4 and finally here
minus H and I think I've got orthogonal
columns again right because the the
columns within these dot products with
themselves give 0 and 0 the dot products
from these columns and these columns
obviously have the minus and the dot
products in here or 0 from that and 0
from that yeah it works and we could
keep going to 16 and 32 and 64 but then
up comes a question what about H 12 is
there ones and minus ones matrix of size
12 12 by 12 it
it doesn't come directly from our little
pattern which is doubling size every
time but you could still hope and it
works there is a I don't know what it is
but there's a there's a matrix of ones
and minus ones orthogonal twelve
orthogonal columns so the answer is yes
okay so we make an 1806 five conjecture
every matrix every matrix size well not
every matrix size because 3x3 is not
going to work one by one is not going to
work either but age twelve works
h/h sixteen what's our conjecture we
won't be the first conjecture --it that
there is a ones and minus ones
orthogonal matrix with orthogonal
columns of every size n so always so so
I'll start to conjecture always possible
if and which is the size of the matrix
let's say what would you guess just take
a shot you won't be asked for a proof
because nobody has the proof even well
you could hope for even you could look
for try six I guess would be the first
guy there and I don't think it's
possible I think six is not possible so
every even sizes is I think not gonna
work but it's natural idea to try what's
the next thought every multiple of four
if n over four is a whole number
so but nobody has a way a systematic way
to create these things so like some of
them are we're at this point we're down
to doing it one at a time and we're up
to 668 but we haven't got that one yet
isn't that crazy so all this is coming
from Wikipedia my source of my short
mice my source of all its good in
mathematics is there on Wikipedia anyway
this is the conjecture conjecture means
you don't have any damn idea of whether
it's true or not that every is that
divisible by four yeah I guess it would
be right 600 certainly is and 68 yeah
okay
so I think that's the first one that's
so anybody if if you find one of size
six six you just skip the homework and
tell us about that one but I don't think
I'll assign them yeah I guess well yeah
I must have searched for it online yeah
anyway so those are the Adam are
matrices now where else do I remember
orthogonal matrices coming from well
yeah really the biggest source of some
what I'm looking for orthogonal matrices
I'm looking for a basis of orthogonal
vectors and we're in math am I going to
find vectors that come out to be
orthogonal we haven't seen that's the
next section of the notes but maybe you
were remembering where will we sort of
like automatically show up with
orthogonal vectors they could be the
eigenvectors of symmetric matrix and
that's where the most important ones
come from oh I could tell you about
wavelets though wavelets are more like
this picture they're ones and minus ones
or the simplest wavelets are ones
- once can I cut it before I go on to
the to the eigenvector business can I
mention the wavelets matrices yeah these
are these are really important simple
and important constructions so wavelets
let me yeah let me draw a picture of so
so I'm going to come up with four-way
I'll do the four by four case and and
this is these these are the orthogonal
guys and then the next one is up and
down and 0 and the last one is 0 and up
and down so that's that's for things but
let me show you the matrix so I'll call
it W for wavelets so that guy I'm
thinking I was 1 1 1 1 this guy I'm
thinking of as 1 1 minus 1 minus 1 it's
looking sort of atom hard way but but
there's a difference here this guy is 1
minus 1 0 0 so the wavelets rescale
that's that's the difference between
atom arden wavelets wavelets are scaling
self scaling and what's the last guy
here what's the fourth column from that
fourth wavelet 0 0 1 minus 1 yeah so har
came up with that this is the haar
wavelet which was many years before the
word wavelets was invented he came up
with this construction the horror horror
the horror matrix there are functions so
they're very simple functions but you
know you can
that makes them usable that's the fact
that they're so simple now I don't know
if we want
see the pattern an eight-by-eight but
let me start the 8x8 so you you'll know
what wavelets are about you'll know what
these horror wavelets are about anyway
they're they're the ones that were that
we're kind of easy to visualize so let's
this is if that's w-4 let's let's just
take a minute
it won't take long for WH okay so the
first column is going to be eight ones
okay
and what's the next column gonna be four
ones and four minus ones like so so four
ones and four minus ones
okay and now the next color - ones - -
ones and zeros right 1 1 minus 1 minus 1
and 0 and the fourth will be zeros and
two ones and two months we got half a
matrix now now if we just tell me the
fifth I'm what do you think what do I
put in the fifth one so again it's gonna
squeeze down and rescale and what's the
fifth column up here that's gonna be
ones and minus ones and zeros now so
it's not at AMARG
it's har and what should I put 1 1 how
they start with 1 101 my yeah and then
all those zeros oh yeah thanks perfect 1
minus 1 and they're all zeros and then
the next three column says we'll have
the 1 minus 1 here and the 1 minus 1
here and the 1 minus 1 here and I saw
zeros yeah so you see the pattern it's
scaling at every step
and and the so that matrix has the
advantage of being quite sparse sort of
this this in my mind is a or but for
ones that's involved with like taking
the average then this guy is like taking
the differences differences between
those and those and then this is like
taking the difference at a smaller scale
I'm not also at a smaller scale so
that's what we keep doing yeah yeah
so that's wavelets it looks so simple
right but at the just a one minute
history of wavelet Sohar invented this
in like 1910 I mean along forever but
then you wanted wavelets that were a
little better and not just ones and
minus ones and zeros and it that took
some some a lot of thinking a lot of
people were searching for it and Ingrid
dobashi
so I'll just put her name became famous
for finding them so in about 1988 she
found a lot of families of wavelets and
when I say wavelets she found a whole
lot of orthogonal matrices that were
that had good properties yep so that's
that's the wave of a picture okay now to
close today and to connect with the next
lecture on eigenvalues eigenvectors
positive definite matrices we're really
getting to the heart of things here
let me follow through on that idea
so the eigenvectors of symmetric matrix
but also of an orthogonal matrix are
orthogonal and that is really where
people where you can invent because you
don't have to work hard you just find a
symmetric matrix its eigenvectors are
automatically orthogonal that doesn't
mean they're great for for use but some
of them are really important and that
may be the most important of all is the
fourier so you probably have seen
Fourier series sines and cosines those
guys are orthogonal functions but
discrete Fourier series is what
everybody computes and those are
orthogonal vectors so the orthogonal
vectors that go into the discrete
Fourier transform and and then they're
done at high speed by the fast Fourier
transform
those are eigenvectors of q eigenvectors
of the right q so let me just invent the
right tell you the right q that get
whose eigenvectors so so i here we go
I can vectors of Q let me you will just
be amazed by how simple this matrix is
it's just that matrix it's a called a
permutation matrix it just puts the
those are the four eight for Fourier
discrete discrete let me put their word
discrete up here transfer
so I really meant to put discrete
Fourier transform yeah
the eigenvectors of that matrix first of
all they are orthogonal and then second
and more important they're they're
tremendously useful they're the they're
the heart of signal processing you know
in in signal processing they just take
the discrete Fourier transform of a
vector before they even look at it I
mean it's like that's the way to see it
is split it into its frequencies and
that's what the eigenvectors of this
will do so we're going to see the
discrete Fourier transform and but my
point here is to know that they're
orthogonal is just comes out of this
fact that the eigenvectors are
orthogonal for any Q and that is
certainly a Q everybody can see that
those columns are orthogonal the columns
of a print that's a permutation matrix
right it's a you've taken the columns of
the identity which are totally
orthogonal and you just put them in a
different order so a permutation matrix
is a reordering of the identity matrix
it's got to be a q and therefore its
eigenvectors are orthogonal and they're
just the winners i mean that the the
matrix of the fourier matrix with those
four eigen vectors in it I'll show you
now okay so this is really we're
finishing today by leading into
Wednesday
I can vectors and eigen values and we
happen to be doing eigen vectors and
eigen values of a queue not today of an
S well most of the time it's a symmetric
matrix whose eigenvectors we take but
here that happens to be a q can I show
you the eigenvectors
the four eigenvectors of that now oh the
complex number I is going to come in you
have to you have to let it in here yeah
sorry ma if s if s is a real symmetric
matrix its eigenvectors are real but if
q is a orthogonal matrix its
eigenvectors even though it's you know
you couldn't ask for a more real matrix
than that but its eigenvectors are at
least yeah the one the good way are
complex numbers so can I show you the
eigenvectors of so again overall the
point today is to see orthogonal
matrices so I'll just repeat now while I
can
rotations here reflections wavelets the
householder idea of reflections of big
large matrices that have this form I
minus 2 uu transpose orthogonal and now
we're going to see the big guys the the
eigenvectors of q right yes oh yeah we
don't have orthonormal that's right we
don't have orthonormal I better divide
by square root of 8 right oh yeah so
you're right sorry I thought I'd get
away with that but I didn't yeah so
these guys are screws of 8 so are these
but these guys are fruits of 4 and these
guys are screw to - thank you absolutely
right absolutely yeah
okay so what are the eigenvectors of a
of a permutation this is going to be
nice to see and I'll use the matrix F
for the eigenvector matrix of that of
that of that queue up there and F is for
for you and it be the four by four for a
matrix okay what are the eigenvectors of
Q okay so Q is a permutation so like I'm
gonna ask you for one eigenvector of
every permutation matrix what what
vector can you tell me that it actually
the eigenvalue will be one what vector
can you tell me where if i permute it I
don't change it one one one one it's
like it's everywhere here one one one
one so that's the zero frequency Fourier
vector
the constant vector all ones everybody
sees that if I I multiply by Q it
doesn't change okay now the next one
I'll show you the for now the next one
will be one I I squared and I cubed
of course I squared I don't know how
many course 6j people are in this
audience but this is a math building we
pay for it it's to 190 and it's I in
this room yeah
so anyway I is the first letter in in
what imaginary thank you the first
letter in imaginary you can't say
imaginary so so so that's it okay and
then the next one is one I squared I
fourth I six and the next one is one I
cubed I six an i-9
that's isn't that just beautiful and you
could
show that every one of those four
columns if you multiply them by Q you
would get the eigenvalues and you would
see that it's an eigenvector and this is
just sort of like a discrete fourier
stuff and you know instead of e to the I
II to the IX e to the 2i X e to the 3 IX
and so on we just have vectors but I so
those are the four eigenvectors of the
of that of that permutation and those
are orthogonal because I just check that
how do you know that this first column
in the second well I should really say
0th column and first column if I'm if
I'm talking frequencies do you see that
that's orthogonal to that well Y is one
plus I plus I squared plus I cube equal
zero that's the dot product this is
column 1 dot column 2 yeah yeah you're
right
this happens to come out 0 is that right
that'll come out 0 but somebody
mentioned that this isn't right this is
I mean that it's true that that came out
0 but when I have imaginary vector
imaginary numbers so anywhere around
this isn't the correct dot product to
test orthogonal if I have imaginary
complex vectors if I have complex
numbers complex vectors I should test
column 1 conjugate dotted with column 2
column I conjugate well let me take
column C what which one shall I take
maybe that guy in that guy many of them
you luck out here but but really I
should be
taking their conjugate so so so these
ones but the thing is the country the
complex conjugate of one is one so that
was that was okay but in general if I
wanted to take column two dotted with
column I don't know maybe four would be
a little dodgy yeah look look what
happens
take that column and that column take
their dot product do it the wrong way so
what's the wrong way
forget about the complex conjugate and
just do it the usual way so one times
one is one I times I cube is 1 I squared
times I six is one I'm getting all ones
I'm not getting a orthogonality there
and that's because I forgot that I
should take the complex conjugate well
of these guys one I should take minus I
minus I square minus i well that's real
so it's okay - they're so so minus I
squared is still minus one so now if I
do it it comes out zero so so let me
repeat again let me just make this
statement if Q transpose Q is I and Q X
is lambda X and Q Y is a different eigen
value Y okay so I'm I'm setting up the
main fact that in the last minute I'm
just gonna write down so I have an
orthogonal matrix I have an eigenvector
with eigenvalue lambda I have another
eigenvector with a different eigen value
mu then the claim is that what is the
claim about the eigenvectors so here's
has one eigen this has an eigen value
this has a different eigen value
I need them to be different to really
know that they're the XS and the Y's
can't be the same so what is it that I
want to show yes that X I have to
remember to do that X transpose Y is 0
that's orthogonality that's
orthogonality for complex vectors I have
to remember to take the to change every
I to a minus I in one of the vectors and
I can prove that fact by playing with
these these by playing with starting
from here I can get to that ok that's it
we've done a lot today a lot of stuff
about orthogonal matrices important ones
and the sources of important ones I ghen
vectors and so it'll be eigenvectors on
Wednesday